hi I'm Arturo Congo I'm a younger
Bolivia the work on me forum and I'm
recording from Rio in the program for
meeting on naughty america so my job was
moderate and need a session on how
global key risks are going to impact on
American the next decade we came up with
I think two main conclusions of global
risk are kind of important for the
region one is the global economy and in
particular the economy of China the
Latin America has been growing in the
past five years and is expected to grow
but next ten years based a lot of
commodity prices and that China has been
very much behind that i would say India
as well the reservation but there is a
risk that the slowing down of China's
growth will actually produce slowly
nanofied demand for our product and thus
a problem for our growth so that's kind
of the first risk that was clearly
identified as a shared regional impact
of that global situation the second is a
global local which the hostel with
demography actually and for all of you
looking at this in youtube or this all
social media social meet different
virtual media actually you are the group
that is growing the fastest in this
continent and we are the youngest
getting to be the youngest continent and
that creates an opportunity but also
risk that if we don't create the jobs
with Bianca don't create opportunities
for you to do something will you light
something productive but also something
fun and interesting basically the
acceptance of a political system and the
acceptance of
and economic model will actually
diminish so that's a again a global
situation that presents a risk but also
an opportunity for Latin America and the
third with very small local and global
has to do with the illegal industries
and the legal economy and by that we
mean drug trafficking human trafficking
which is actually more common in the
region that we may think and that's one
that has the electric connotations
direct implications for governance if
you don't have strong governance from
judicial systems is really hard to deal
with